this is video from the march for our
lives rally held earlier today here in
las vegas jeremy j ford was there and
shares more on the pleas for change
[Music]
save our kids not the guts around 100
people fed up this is madness sick of
all this pain and hurt and i'm sick of
the government not doing anything the
issue at hand gun control recent mass
shootings are spurring nationwide
protests this is what it looked like
today here in las vegas
[Applause]
chants like these that resonate with
sarah mcgowan a mother who knows the
pain of losing a child all too well i
know what that feels like i know what
all these parents are going through
across the united states the trauma
the guilt the
anxiety
the missing them never goes away it's a
crisis that's kelly needer a teacher
who's demanding change and action i wish
that children dying was not a
political stance i feel like we're
divided but i feel like if we don't take
action it will just continue to happen
offering solutions to anyone who will
listen i would love if the age was 21
for a weapon in our country not 18
i would love if there were background
checks so that people had to do their
due diligence to get these weapons that
are murdering our children do something
stop this madness human beings are being
slaughtered the protest lasted about an
hour but wrapped up early due to the
heat but those who were there hope their
message pushes lawmakers to do something
anything
jeremy j ford live local now
now we reached out to the nevada firearm
coalition for their take on today's
rally they are a group backed by the nra
we did not hear back from them in time
for this broadcast